When I was talking to Gregg last night I noticed that he sounded
Horribly sick
And I did he says he feels fine
But he's still coughing and wheezing and hacking so I'm making him where I'm making him wear the mask to keep us all safe
All of us not just not just the people in the studio people listening to this podcast now
Let's go to Los Angeles where last week the Rams beat the Seahawks?
But probably the most noteworthy thing from the game
Where was that two different players Tyler Lockett of the Seahawks and Brandon cooks of the rams
Went out of their way to give a football to Floyd Mayweather after scoring a touchdown. Yeah Floyd medley way
There was a in the front row in the end zone and a couple teams came and gave him give him footballs
One person from each team scored a touchdown and gave him the football Cooke said I go kind of track the ball down
So he could get it and give yeah
But it wasn't like he had to run like he spiked it and I was like I want to give him anyway
I was pretty cool. I liked the Greg actually tweeted about this and I think that I think the actual tweet was
Giving Floyd Mayweather. The the football man zone is the touch TD celebration of the year
I know cuz I like the tweet and then you deleted it probably rightly
So I almost never delete any tweets, but it felt like I was trying to you know
kind of make fun of the situation but then
You know the nuance maybe would have been been lost on some of the people it didn't didn't seem worth
I don't know whining anyone surprised, you know
I mean you got you got two teams playing football and then you've got one of the biggest
Domestic violence abusers in the world that we know of sitting in the front row. You got to get him the ball
You got to get involved, you know, both teams have domestic abusers on them
of course they do and yeah, they're playing they're playing a little hearts out giving 110% but when he got Floyd
Beat up every woman. He's ever dated Mayweather sitting in the front row. You gotta get on the ball
You gotta feed him the ball either team giving them the ball. I think that's what the NFL is all about, especially in
November
Gregg what you have to say about that
Anything about that so your theory here is that
Even in a field of athlete's foot in in domestic abusers that you're saying Floyd Mayweather it stands apart
I'm seeing the NFL more than any other league values certain qualities and it's in its athletes and
Domestic abuse certainly seems to be up near the top of the list. They've been
I'm surprised they don't they don't make it part of the combine
The way the league is going so when you see Floyd Mayweather, you gotta get him the damn ball
And that's what they did Greg you chicken down
by the way
My little more like menacing with this mask on you feel like you can't see me smiling saying over these things you're like bang so
listeners to the decimal Nick and Rosenthal vanity project
Junior vice president well know that last week
We really created a stir with our talked about the migrant Caravan and okay
The election happened and it's been out of the news
But you know what the migrant Caravan it's still it's still heading north hasn't even slowed down
No, it's opting for a safer slightly different route now
There was an update on Tuesday, but we've been getting a lot of questions about but if anything
I think the Caravan sped up. Do you know I mean, they know we've been talking about him and
There were a lot of critics last week saying we shouldn't have talked about this
But listen, even though the elections over and people when talking about it, we're gonna dig deep and we're gonna keep talking about the caravan
every single episode
Until some of them are in our government
like until they've reached that level we talked about them if they could play in the NFL last year over last week and you were
Saying they would get crushed by other teams
And I think a lot of that was it was your political bias
But now that you've kind of done a little deeper digging into the caravan
What are the chances the NFL would expand the caravan? I?
was like because think about they were gonna have a game in Mexico City, you know that they could be the Mexico City Caravan and
Which is a better name than a lot of teams out and they could turn around. I mean you're right
I feel like the NFL after
Taking this game. It was supposed to be in Mexico City. The field wasn't ready
So now they're moving it to Los Angeles. They need to make it up to that market
Turn the caravan around start getting ready for 2019 does anyone I mean does anyone else in the NFL think it's hilarious
The game was canceled due to landscaping problems
Like no one made a joke about that like that's that's the issue guys get it together down there
I think that you know the NFL's about money, but I bet if you get these four thousand migrants together
Turn them upside down shake them. They gotta have some money on them pull that money together
You can buy yourself an NFL team. I mean they could they could be like the Green Bay Packers
Only they own themselves. It's not just the city that owns the team the caravan owns its own team
And we've been I've sent some scouts out there to get some forty times
See what kind of vertical leap they got
But I think the caravan I think their playoff team next year. I mean
But the the NFL is all about merchandising, you know, that's why they have every team as so many different types of uniforms
What would the mascot be for the caravan?
Maybe just just an actual
Caravan, I wake some heads that's a you could not have used your imagination less to come up with the mascot for the caravan
Then you just did great. I think a crying baby a
Crying baby would be the mascot almost like actually is that the mascot of the New Orleans pelicans?
They have the king cake baby. King cake, baby. Yeah, it would be like that only darker
I think that would be a good like the huddle buddy
You tell me you wouldn't buy the Mexico City caravans huddle, buddy
The NFL's been looking for like a way to do kind of a Developmental League ever since NFL Europe
Has been gone. I didn't know it was gone. It's been gone for 20 years now. Okay, so
You mentioned 4,000 people. I mean that they could maybe make a
Caravan league unto its own. It's not just 4,000 people 4,000 athletes
in their prime
That's what I've been told
I just think the NFL is gonna get bigger and better and
This Caravan is the answer to almost all the problems and listen. Let me tell you something else
I've been looking at the comments on the videos people getting upset
yeah, there's videos on YouTube of to the podcast a lot of very upset people people were yelling at me forgetting about the politics let
me say this without
involving politics whatsoever
Zero politics. No red. No blue. No anything if you were afraid of the caravan
You were small if you were afraid of immigrants
You were small if you were afraid of women
If you were a misogynist you were small if you were afraid of black people you were a small person and you were scared
Don't be small
America is not small be big like me
Be I'm I weigh a fucking ton and I'm not threatened or scared of any Caravan or any woman
Or any black person or even Greg's wife none of them?
You